hi
welcome to valuation
i know many of you come in with
preconceptions about what this class is
about
and rather than feed into those
preconceptions
i'd like to talk about what this class
is not about and in the process perhaps
perhaps you will get a sense of what
this class is about
i know for many of you valuation is a
set of equations and formula and models
and perhaps that is what you're
expecting to get as science
i'm sorry to disappoint you but
valuation is not a science it is a craft
and the essence of a craft is you learn
through trial and error there is no
perfect way of doing things there's a
better way of doing things
put simply you don't learn valuation by
talking about it or watching other
people talk about it
so i hope that this class will help you
learn valuation as a craft by doing it
you will find that as you work through
this class it will get easier when you
start it's going to be difficult that's
the nature of a craft and as you get
more comfortable you'll start to get
more comfortable also deviating from a
script
rather than cook from a recipe you'll be
able to cook on your own
second
i know for many of you you're expecting
a class built around valuing publicly
traded companies
you want to value the coca-colas the
airbnbs the ubers the facebooks of the
world and that's okay that's pretty much
what many people think about valuation
but i hope to make this class much more
than valuing just public companies i
want to talk about valuing private
companies i want to talk about buying
small companies and large companies
develop market companies in emerging
market companies and along the way what
i hope you will see in this class is the
principles of valuation are universal
you don't really need to relearn
valuation to value a specific group of
companies you just need to take the
existing principles evaluation and apply
them differently
along the way we'll talk about how value
can be different from the inside when
managers look at a company i suppose
from the outside as investors looking at
a company not because the principles
change but because managers control more
of the levers they can change the way a
companies run
by the end of this class i hope you can
value just about any kind of business
small or large in whatever sector in
whatever market
third i want to draw a contrast between
two words we use interchangeably in
investing value and price
let me set this on the table if i
believe that markets were efficient what
i'm effectively saying the value and the
price are pretty much the same thing and
if you believe that there's really no
point taking this class
i believe that the value of an asset is
driven by cash flows growth and risk and
we're going to talk a lot about how to
value an asset in this class
but we're also going to talk about how
to price that same asset what does that
mean to price an asset you look at what
other assets just like it are being
priced at in the market and i'm going to
argue that the pricing process can give
your number very different than the
value process
we're going to go through both valuing
and pricing assets along the way and
we're going to look at some investments
that cannot be valued currencies for
instance cannot be valued they can only
be priced a collectible cannot be valid
it can only be priced
fourth i'm going to surprise you i know
many of you are going to come into this
class expecting to see excel
spreadsheets
and i'll make a confession i've never
opened an excel spreadsheet in the
context of a class
to me the essence of evaluation is not
the collection of numbers that make it
but the story behind the numbers
you can hear a lot of storytelling in
this class but storytelling with a
purpose
where every number in my evaluation is
connected to a story and every story i
tell you about a company is connected to
numbers
finally
i don't believe in valuing things just
for the sake of valuing them i'm a
pragmatist
i believe that if you value something
you need to be willing to act on it what
does that mean if you find something to
be undervalued you have to be willing to
buy it you're saying so what's so
difficult about doing that
you're going to recognize that there's a
difference between figuring out that
something is misvalued and acting on it
and that difference can be bridged only
with faith faith in what faith in your
own value and faith that markets will
correct that price will move to value
much more difficult than it sounds on
the outside
so what i hope to during this do during
this class is not just deliver the
techniques and the tools evaluation but
give you some insight into how you can
connect stories to value the difference
between value and price and how you go
about acquiring the faith to be able to
act on evaluations
i hope you will find this class useful
no matter what perspective
you bring into the class